قالت قيادات في مجلس سياده السوداني انه
لا هدنه مع قوات الدعم الا بعدما وصفته
بتنظيف وتامين الخرطوم ومدن اخرى مضيفه ان
منبره جدا التفاوضي تشوبه نواقص تتعلق
باليات وقضايا اجرائيه لا يمكن ايقاف
الحرب دون حسمها في المقابل قالت قوات
الدعم ان وقت السلام حان وانها مستعده
للمشاركه في اي اجتماعات تقود اليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الخلفيات الميدانيه
والسياسيه لاخر المواقف الصادره عن قيادات
في مجلس سياده السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع بخصوص مساعي وقف اطلاق النار
بينهما ما مقصود مجلس السياده السوداني من
وراء الحديث عن ان منبره جدا تنقصه اليات
وقضايا اجرائيه وما موقف قوات الدعم من
ذلك وما رؤيه الطرفين كان يتم تفعيل ذلك
المنبر على النحو المطلوب لوقف اطلاق
النار الى ماذا قد تتطور مواقف طرفي
الازمه من مجرياتها الحاليه والجهود
الراميه الى انهائها في ضوء المواقف
المستجده من الدول الافريقيه وتصعيد لهجه
مجلس السياده تجاه كيمياء
[موسيقى]
بعد طيها مائه يوم تراوح الحرب في السودان
مكانها دون افق قريب لوقف اطلاق النار
تعددت المنابر والتفاوضيه وبقيت تعقيدات
السلام مستعصيه على مبادرات السلام
الاقليميه والقاريه والدوليه جدا مثلت
واحده من تلك المحطات وها هي تجد امامها
شروطا وملاحظات نقديه في طريقها الواعر
نحو اسكات البنادق وحقن الدماء نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني مالك عجار قال ان
المفاوضات تعاني من اشكاليه تتمثل بعدم
وجود التبعات والاجراءات المتعلقه بتنفيذ
الهدن بين الطرفين المستشار السياسي لقوات
الدعم السريع يوسف عزت اكد استعداد الدعم
السريع للمشاركه في اي نوع من الاجتماعات
لاحلال السلام وفي ظل الاتهامات التي تصدر
بين حين واخر لطرفي القتال بارتكاب
انتهاكات خطيره لحقوق الانسان قال الاتحاد
الاوروبي انه يعتزم وضع اطار عمل لعقوبات
تستهد اطراف الفاعله في الازمه السودانيه
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
فرحان حق اشار مركزا على الجانب الانساني
الى ان السودان
يعد في الوقت الحالي احد اكثر الاستجابات
الانسانيه تعقيدا في العالم
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم حافظ
كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن الخرطوم
عبر الهاتف اللواء المتقاعد الدكتور امين
اسماعيل مجذوب الخبير في اداره الازمات
والتفاوض في مركز البحوث الاستراتيجيه
اهلا وسهلا بكم ما ابدا منك سياده اللواء
اذا كان بالامكان تفهم الجوانب الاجرائيه
وضروره التقيد بالتنفيذ وما الى ذلك من
الامور فما المغزى من ربط كل ذلك بتنظيف
وتامين الخرطوم ومدن اخرى في البلاد خاصه
في دارفور
بهذا الا يبدو في الامر نوع من
التعجيز وبعض قد يقول وضع العربه امام
الحصان
مساء الخير مرحبا بك ومرحبا
وبضيفك الكريم
واضح انه تفكير وخطط واستراتيجيه القوات
المسلحه السودانيه تنطلق من عدم التزام
عناصر الدعم السريع في البدن
العشره هدى لم تلتزم بالخروج من الاعيان
المدنيه وتشمل منازل المواطنين
والمستشفيات وفتح المسارات الانسانيه
والنهب والسلب الذي تم في العاصمه وفي
دارفور
وجرائم ضد الانسانيه تمت في منطقه الجنينه
ونيالا
هذه الامور تم ربطها الان بوجود اليات
لاجزام عناصر الدعم السريع بالالتزام بهذه
الموجهات ثم وجود ما يفصل بين الغودين
وضمان تسليم
الاسلحته وخروجه من العاصمه اعتقد انه هذه
الادوات التي كان يقصدها السيد السياده
وبالتالي الحكومه السودانيه تعول على منبر
الجده ولكن ارى انها تميل الى توثيق العمل
باعتبار ان كل الهدى لم يتم التنفيذ
والالتزام بها من جانب عضلات السريع وهي
الان في تقدير تحقق بعض الانتصارات على
الارض وتعمل على
تضييق الخناقه على عناصر التي تعمل سريع
وبالتالي اما ان يكون هنالك التزام او ان
تسير في الحجر العسكري طيب دعنا نسال
السيد حافظ كبير عن عن جدوى اي هدنه ايضا
في ظل استمرار الوضع الامني على حاله عدم
الالتزام باي عدن ناهيك عن الانتهاكات
التي تحدث والتي يدينها الجميع
تحيه طيبه
لكل المشاهدين انا اعتقد الحديث عن الهدنه
او الحديث عن اي هدنه هو حديث يعني
تحدث الفروع وليس حديث القضايا الاساسيه
القضيه الاساسيه هي التفاوض حول القضايا
التي بسببها اندلع النزاع في السودان
وبالتالي اذا استعصى على الاطراف او حتى
على الوساطه ايجاد اليات
لتحقيق هدنه وفق ما تعتبرها الاطراف
المختلفه تعريفاتها المختلفه للهدنه هذا
يمكن تجاوزه والدخول مباشره الى الى لب
الموضوع الى مراقشه القضايا الرئيسيه نحن
ندخل اليوم الشهر الرابع والهدنه بالاساس
من اجل حمايه المدنيين المدنيين الذين
يعني يعمل الاطراف على حمايتهم حتى الان
يعني عانوا ما عانوا من انتهاكات حتى من
ظروف الحرب الذين حتى خرجوا من ولايه
الخرطوم لم يسلموا من اثار الحرب وبالتالي
اذا كان هناك من يريد تحقيق السلام او
يريد وضع حد لهذا النزاع المستمر عليه
تجاوز مساله الهدنه ومساله الالتزام بها
لان التعريفات واضح جدا ان تعريف القوات
المسلحه للهدنه يختلف عن تعريف الدعم
السريع وكذلك لا يمكن سريعا ان تشرح لنا
هل يمكن سريعا ان تشرح لنا هذه النقطه
ماذا يعني ذلك
كيف يفهم الدعم السريع الهدنه وكيف يفهمها
الجيش ويعني عندما عندما عند تقول ان هناك
هدنه لا يعني ذلك انك ستوقف الحرب انك
يعني تسحب جنودك من الاماكن التي يعني كنت
فيها هذا لا يعني ذلك وبالتالي بالنسبه
للجيش الطائرات كانت تحلق طائرات الحربيه
الاستكشافيه التي تصور او ترصد اماكن
القوه وتقول بان القوه متحركه ينبغي معرفه
ان هذه القوه المنتشره على نطاق واسع من
الولايات الخرطوم والولايات اخرى لا بد
لها ان تتحرك ما بين الارتكازات المختلفه
للتواصل وبالتالي لا هذه الحركه تعتبرها
القوات المسلحه خرق للهدنه وهذا غير صحيح
وبالتالي ينبغي تجاوز هذه النقطه وهي
بالاساس ليست ليست موضوع الصراع هي هي من
اي حمايه المدينه او من اجل تخفيف الحرب
على المدنيه وبالتالي ينبغي الذهاب الى
الفكره دكتور امين يعني ما سمع من اعضاء
مجلس السياده وخاصه السيد مالك عجار هل
يعني فيما يخص منبر جدا تفوضيه بشكل محدد
ان هذا لن يستمر الا وفق الشروط التي
ذكرها
من من قبيل تامين الخرطوم وتامين المدن
الاخرى وكل ما الى ذلك
تجريب المجرب
سيؤدي الى الندامه حوالي 12 هدنه لم يتم
الالتزام بها لم يتم فتح المسارات
الانسانيه لحمايه المواطنين ليستمر السلب
والنهر وبالتالي القوات المسلحه لم تفرد
في امضى المواطنين
لابد من اعاده تعريف
الحركه الخاصه بالقوات سواء كان العناصر
الدعم السريع او القوات المسلحه القوات
المسلحه تدافع عن وطنه في بلدك من اتى من
خارج السودان ومن اتى من مناطق ناهيه في
دارفور
وهاجم المواطنين والسلب هذا هو الذي يحتاج
الى تعريف عموما القوات المسلحه لا تشترط
واعتقد انها لم تضع عصابات امام التفاوض
وانما
انه الهدى السابقه الالتزام بها وبالتالي
لابد من وجود ادوات ومراغبه
بشريه بدلا من المراقبه بالعماره
الاصطناعيه وبالتالي مخاطبه جذور المشكله
الاشكاليه كلها كانت دمج الدعم السريع رفض
الدعم السريع قام باحتلال مطارات قامه
بمهاجمه القوات المسلحه وكان يتحدث عن
الديمقراطي والحكم المدني فاي اي مدنين
تريد ان تحكمهم وانت الان تسلبهم وتدخل
بمنازلهم وتغتصب نسائهم وتسرق اموالهم
وبالتالي هذه الامور لا اعتقد هنالك جيش
في العالم يقبل بتجاوزها حسنا
في نطاق سياسي سيد حافظ كبير ما يقوله
المستشار السياسي في الدعم السريع يوسف
عزت عن القبول بالذهاب الى اي مفاوضات كيف
يمكن التاسيس عليه وهو يقول هذا يعني في
المطلق لا يفترض ان يكون هناك تهدئه وفي
اجواء هذه التهدئه تتم مناقشه كل التفاصيل
وبالطبع منذ اليوم الاول منذ اشتعال
الصراع الدعم السريع ضل يؤكد بانه مستعد
للجلوس وللتفاوض هذا الامر يعاني الجديد
على القوات المسلحه ان تقبل بالتفاوض لان
المعلوم عنها مواقفها انها كانت رافضه او
انها كانت تتحدث باكثر من لسان الحديث
الذي يتحدث به ياسر عطا يختلف عن الحديث
الذي يتحدث به القاعده العامه وكذلك باشي
وهذا يعني هذا هو الذي يحتاج الى اعاده
تعريف مساله التفاوض كيف يرون كيف كيف
يعرفون التفاوض في ظل يعني الرغبه في
الاستمرار في الحرب كيف يرون ايضا رؤيتهم
للسلام في ظل تعريفهم للدعم السريع تعريف
خاطئ وهو ان الدعم السريع قوات ربما كما
ذكر ضيفك الكريم قبل قليل بانها جاءت من
خارج الحدود هي قوات كانت الى الامس
القريب جزء من القوات المسلحه وبالتالي
هذا امر يعني
يراد منه فقط رفع السقوفات وبالتالي هذه
الاشترا التي وضعها ياسر العطا يعني لا
يستطيع تنفيذها هو الق لم تستطع حمايه
نفسها وحمايه قيادتها وبالتالي مساله
حمايه المواطنين ايضا هذا امر يعني يراد
به رفع الروح المعنويه بان هناك تقدم في
المعارك هذا غير صحيح الصحيح ان الطرفين
من تامين المواطنين المسؤولين من تامين
البلاد بنص القانون ونص الدستور وبالتالي
حدث نزاع بينهم حول الرؤيه التي
تتحدث تتحدث عن مغادره الوصل العسكريه
للسياسه وتسليم السلطه المدنيين وكان هناك
اتفاق يجري الجميع يعلم ذلك البعض يريد
التنصل من هذا الاتفاق لكن هذا لم يحدث
التفاوض الذي يهرب منه قيادات في القوات
المسلحه يعيد العمليه السياسيه النقاشات
السياسيه والقضايا الجذريه للخلاف وللصراع
حتى مساله دمج الدعم السريع لم تكن مرفوضه
وانما جاءت في سياق الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري وهي مطلوبه يعني دعنا نتقدم الى
الامام في هذا لا تحتاج الى اصلاح حاليا
في هذا النقاش دكتور امين الاحاديث
المسؤولين في الجيش هل يفهم منه ان
المفاوضات في جده هناك نواقص تشوبها
والغابت هذه النواقص عن الامريكيين
والسعوديين
في تقديري الوفد المفاوض لديه تفويض كامل
لديه سقف تفاوضه اعلى وثق في ادنى السقف
الادنى هو يجب ان تكون هنالك الزاميه
بالمبادئ الخاصه بالهدل او بوقف اطلاق
النار اللي هو هيغوت الى التفاوض بالقضايا
الاخرى ايضا مساله الفصل بين القوات
باخراج قوات الدعم السريع من العاصمه هذا
امر مهم جدا وبالتالي انا اعتقد انهم لا
يرفضون التفاوض وانهم جاهزون وهنالك حديث
لعدد من اعطائهم في السياده العسكريين
الاسبوع الماضي انهم يتجهون الى التفاوض
ويرحبون باي منبر من المناظر الذي يقود
الى السلام اعتقد انه لم يفوت على السيده
مولدي قبل اسبوعين تحدثت عن ان منبر جده
لا يتوافق مع الخطه الامريكيه هذه نقطه
مهمه جدا خطه امريكيه يجري لاعداد لها
تحتوي على جانب عسكري على جانب سياسي
وبالتالي الان هي تعرض على الاطراف
وهذه الخطه ربما تعيد المشهد السابق قبل
الحرب ولكن بفاعلين جدد
شكل جديد وبالتالي تختلف التحالفات
المحليه
ما الذي تقصده بذلك بشكل يتوافق مع ما
يريده الجيش ام العكس
الخطه الامريكيه تتحدث عن تسليم السلطه
المدنيين الان وخروج المكون العسكري بشقيه
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع لكن بدون
دمج الدعم السريع تكون هنالك غاطره براسين
او دوله في جيشين فلا نريد ان نكرر
النموذجي اللبناني بوجود قوات مسلحه ووجود
قوات اخرى لابد من حسم
امر سريع وبالتالي القوات المسلحه يمكن ان
تفاوض على تسليم السلطه مباشره
واعتقد ان الخطه الامريكيه فيها مرونه
وبضمانات سعوديه ومنبر مصر تحدث عن الحفاظ
على
السودانيه السياسيه والعسكريه سيد حافظ
كبير كيف تنظر قوات الدعم السريع اذا كانت
هذه نظره الجيش ما نظره الدعم السريع
للمفاوضات في جده
والاجراءات فيها والاليات والاسس التي
تقوم عليها كل هذه التفاصيل ما هي نظره
الدعم السريعه اليها
وهو بالطبع يعني الوفود لم تغادر جدا ذهبت
الى هناك لتحقيق تحقيق وفاق او اتفاق على
ثلاث مراحل مرحله الانسانيه ومرحله وقف
اطلاق النار لاي مرحله امنيه وعسكريه
وكذلك مرحله سياسيه اعضاء الوفود يعبرون
عن هذه المراحل هناك مستشار للشؤون
الانسانيه وكذلك هناك مستشار لشؤون
القانونيه وهناك يعني مختصون في الملف
السياسي الملف السياسي اطرافه متعدده ليس
ليس فقط الجيش والدعم لكن المفاوضات لم
تبرح الملف الانساني يعني عندما نتحدث
الان نحن فقط في الهدن وكانما المفاوضات
منبر جده مختص فقط بانه يعقد هدنه من اجل
حمايه المجانين وهذا هو يعني جوهر الموضوع
هذا غير صحيح ينبغي يعني الحديث او مناقشه
هذه الملفات في مستوياتها المختلفه الثلاث
الانساني وكذلك الامن والعسكري وكذلك
السياسي الامن العسكري يختصب بالقوتين
هناك رؤيه قديمه ننقشت في الصداقه ضمن
العمليه السياسيه وتتحدث عن الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري هذه يمكن ان تفتح من جديد
الحديث الذي تتحدث به القوات المسلحه من
انها يعني تريد فقط صباح الغد تجد نفسها
مسيطره على كل الامور وان الدعم جزء منها
بامرها دون المرور بمرحله الاصلاح هذا لن
يحدث نحن الان كنا نتخوف من وجود جيشين
الان نحن في الان نعيش فعلا وجود جيشان
وبالتالي ينبغي النقاش حول كيفيه توحيد
هذه هذين الجيشين وفق رؤيه سياسيه تشارك
فيها اطراف سياسيه كذلك وتشارك فيها اطراف
العسكريه من الدعم السريع والجيش كذلك
الانتقال الى العمليه السياسيه يقتضي
استصحاب الاطراف اخرى الحريه والتغيير
وكذلك اطراف السلام
صاحبه مصلحه من العمليه السياسيه وكذلك
صاحب مصلحه من انتقال السلطه للمدنيه
دكتور اسماعيل وساطلب منكم لو سمحتم بعض
الاختصار الان هناك مسار السعوديه في جده
وه مسار الايجاد وهناك يعني ما ذكرته
عن مبادره امريكيه تتحدث عنها دكتور امين
اي هذه المسارات
الاوفر حظا تعتقد والاقدر على
ان ان يعني ان تتقدم في هذه المفاوضات مع
الطرفين
في تقديره ولدت ميته كل التصريحات الصدرت
عنها بعدم وجود نظام وعدم وجود قياده لم
يكن مقبولا ولم يكن دبلوماسيا تغيرت
النبره في
اجتماعات القاهره من الرؤساء الذين حضروا
تحدثوا عن مؤسسات تحدثوا هاتفيا مع رئيس
مجلس السياده لذلك منبر الايجارات في
تقديره ولد ميتا الان لا بد من التنسيق ما
بين منبر جده وما بين مؤتمر دول الجوار
السوداني الذي عرضت في القاهره لديه اليه
تنفيذيه في تشات تعقد بوزراء الخارجيه
وهذه الاليه التنفيذيه يمكن ان تكون مفتاح
الاحداث خط في البوابه المختلفه مع ما
يحدث في جده اعتقد انه يمكن ان يكونوا برا
السلام والامان لما يحدث في السودان الان
سيد حافظ كبير بالنسبه لقوات الدعم السريع
اي هذه الهيئات وال جهات الاقليميه
والدوليه يمكنها ان تحقق تقدما في
المفاوضات
يعني هو بالطبع الهدف الاساسي هو الاصول
الاتفاق بغض النظر عن المنبر لكن اعتقد ان
منبر جده هو منبر يحظى يعني قبول واساس
جيد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لديها علاقات
ولديها معرفه ولديها مصلحه ولديها تاثير
نفوز على الاطراف كذلك الولايات المتحده
لديها ثقل السياسي وكذلك اي اي عمليه
تفاوض تحتاج الى اموال وهذا متوفر في منبج
الدوري التالي ينبغي التركيز الجهود في
منبر جده حتى حتى المنابر الاخرى تتحدث
عنها تدعم السلام بغض النظر عن المنبر
الذي يجد القبول لدى الاطراف الان هناك
تقدم في جده بعكس الايجات التي
تناسبها القوات المسلحه العاداء وكذلك
تصريحات التي صدرت منها لا تبشر بانها
ستقبل بهذا المنبر لكن اعتقد ان منبر جده
يحظى حتى الان باحترام كبير حتى عندما
غادرت القوات المسلحه المنبر
وعلقت المشاركه فيه رجع عدد من جديد
تطالبت الاطراف بالمواصله في هذا المنبر
واعتقد انهم الان يواصلون النقاش في قضايا
مهمه لم يكشف عنها حتى
تقدم كثيرا نحو الى ان الى ان يحين وقت
التفاوض الدكتور امين مره اخرى في جده على
ماذا سيراهن الجيش هل سيراهن على الحسم
على الارض وهل هو قادر على ذلك
اي صراع لا بد ان ينتهي بتفاوض منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
والصراعات الشبيهه في ما حدث في اثيوبيا
كلها يابد ان تنتهي بتفاوض ولكن اذا لم
تحفظ المؤسسات وتحفظ كرامه الدوله وحمايه
المدنيين اعتقد غط يطول امد التفاوض وربما
يكون هنالك تفكير في حسم على الارض
وهذا سيزيد من معاناه الشعب السوداني ومن
معاناه دول الجوار التي تعتمد على السودان
هنالك تبعد الحديثه ليست لديها موانئ
لديها تجاره بينيه يعني 100 يوم من اندلاع
هذه الاشتباكات ويوعد السودانيون بالحسم
العسكري وهذا لم يحدث حتى الان
وبالتالي الى متى
وبالتالي لابد من الجلوس للتفاوض
حسنا
الاتحاد الاوروبي التحق بالولايات المتحده
في التلويح بعقوبات وشيكه كيف ترى هذه
الخطوه وتاثيرها على الحرب في السودان سيد
حافظ كبير وطبعا يعني دعنا اتهامات كثيره
بالانتهاكات موجهه بشكل اكبر بقوات الدعم
السريع
هو بالطبع المواقف الدوليه تؤثر على
الطرفين تؤثر بحيث انها تدفع الاطراف نحو
التفاوض هذا اقصى ما يمكن ان تفعله
العقوبات او التهديدات او حتى المواقف
الذي يريد التفاوض لا يخشى لا يخشى هذه
المواقف لانه ابتداء وافق على ما تريده
الضغوطات الضغوطات كلها تريد التبديل اليه
او تغيير التحويل سلوك الاطراف من السلوك
العنيف سلوك الحرب الى تفاوض وهذا مقبول
ابتداء من الدعم السريع الذي يحتاج الى
الى الحديث معه او الى اجباره نحو التفاوض
القوات المسلحه اعتقد بان المواقف الدوليه
اذا فشلت هناك حقائق في الواقع ستجبر
القوات المسلحه على التفاوض لانها حتى
الان حتى حديثي معك لا تستطيع حتى فردي
حديثه التي تتحدث عنه في ارض الواقع حول
القياده او حتى في القصر الجمهوري او حتى
المقر العسكريه التي تسقط بالتوالي اعتقد
ان اذا واصلت في هذه العمليه
ستتكبث ايضا المزيد من الخساره وبالتالي
الاوفق حفظ كرامتها يعني
العقوبات السابقه اعتقد نبهت الطرفين نبهت
الدعم السريع ونبهت القوات المسلحه ان لا
يتم استعداء النظام الدولي سواء كان مجلس
الامن او الاتحاد الاوروبي او حتى الاتحاد
الافريقي وبالتالي الانتصارات الاعلاميه
لن تجدي وانما الوضع على الارض المراقب من
الجميع هو الذي سيؤدي في النهايه الى
التفاوض ونامل
الاحتكام لصوت العقد من الطرفين وانقاذ
الشعب السوداني من هذه الماساه
شكرا جزيلا لكما اذا من الخرطوم اللواء
المتقاعد الدكتور امين اسماعيل مجذوب
الخبير في اداره الازمات والتفاوض ومن
الخرطوم ايضا حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لكما
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هنا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]